[Musique]
la danse occupe une place centrale dans
la vie de pénélope quirion
six heures par semaine à répéter les
mêmes pas les mêmes gestes
avec des copines tout aussi passionnée
qu'elle
[Musique]
mais aussi créative et exigeante soit
elle les chorégraphies font face à une
concurrence déloyale sitôt que la
musique s'arrête
on met une trente minutes et dès qu'on
était sur mon téléphone qu'on a fait des
tic tac pied si oui on fait l'expliqué
ensemble métier il ya pas tant de social
c'était que manquer les filles ont fait
stocks parce que tu le regardes tu es
comment qui dit bon je leur ai juste à
régler tik tok une plateforme de
diffusion de courtes vidéos
la dernière application à la mode chez
les adolescents
pénélope ne fait pas exception elle y
passe beaucoup de temps
[Musique]
vraiment pas très social
pour sa tournée d'un
parce que tu as donné raison et accros
au téléphone oui totalement
demain est magique et santé fallon
serait pas capable
une dépendance qui touche toute une
génération selon une étude récente 80 %
des adolescents québec ont une présence
sur les réseaux sociaux près de 60 %
d'entre eux passent plus de 10 heures
par semaine sur internet une nouvelle
réalité face à laquelle beaucoup
d'enseignants se sentent désarmés avec
le multimédia les les réseaux sociaux
c'est tout est tellement rapide la
lenteur
maintenant à ce jour rien n'est vraiment
prévu dans le programme éducatif
québécois pour outiller les élèves face
à ce monde numérique dans lequel il
évolue je pense que oui on doit
s'adapter on doit on le fait c'est sauf
qu'on a besoin d'être pour expliquer
enseigner la désinformation ça c'est sûr
quel con et des ateliers des invités qui
viennent dans les écoles c'est super
important
cette école de repentigny a donc décidé
de pallier les lacunes en offrant à ses
élèves un atelier d'information sur
internet et les médias sociaux pour
mieux les comprendre pour mieux les
gérer au même rythme que les activités
sur les écrans mais prend de l'ampleur
dans nos vies on voit en pointillés et
symptômes dépressifs chez les
adolescents car s'ils permettent de
connecter les usagers des médias sociaux
comporte aussi une part de danger
textote instagram est un modèle
économique où nous sommes le produit on
génère des données et ensuite on est
ciblé par des publicités d'apprendre aux
jeunes ça peut permettre de même des
mots puis les théories sur leurs
sentiments pour moi c'est un problème
une pop emmanuel parents est à l'origine
de cette formation
depuis sa mise en place l'atelier
qu'elle a élaboré ces déjà donné des
centaines de fois dans les écoles à
travers la province et vidéo donne le
sourire puisque d'autres choses hier
certains sept scientifiques tirent la
cueillette des impacts négatifs du
numérique sont même bien être puis le
bus avec ses ateliers là c'est d'amener
les jeunes à être capable d'avoir un
esprit critique sur leur utilisation du
numérique on va vers la vie sont
instagram c'est juste du feq sur les
singles justement les gens doutent un
bourricot
depuis qu'en réalité c'est souvent sous
photoshop pour des surfaces et une
réalisation récent car comme beaucoup
d'adolescents de son âge pénélope s'est
longtemps comparé aux vedettes desta g
j'ai commencé à m'entraîner
généralement parce que je voyais les
standards de beauté qui s'était surtout
il faut l'être humain soit l'époque
était trop de cuisses de ventre pas mal
tout légué moi je crois que georges
était abonné sur instagram il faudrait
justement kylie jenner pis moi dans ma
thèse c'est comme
ibo mais comme je sais qu'ils vont être
intéressés seulement si j'ai le corps de
ce fils en classe les formatrices se
garde bien de diaboliser les médias
sociaux ce qu'on propose c'est l'auto
défense numérique l'idée est plutôt
d'échanger avec les élèves ses toiles
importance le corps mais 1er mai mais
puisque qu'ils voient tous les jours ces
réseaux sociaux toujours confronté à ça
et de les amener à réfléchir à
développer une respect critique on peut
pas se permettre de laisser les jeunes
sans guide ans dans cet univers
numérique l'heure les réseaux sociaux
particulièrement exploite une
vulnérabilité psychologique pour
maintenir notre attention pour ce qui
est si important dès qu'on les jeunes
d'apprendre c'est quoi ces mécanismes
leurs pieds de reprendre le contrôle de
notre utilisation un atelier d'une heure
vite écoulée très d'autres personnes qui
ont quelque chose à acheter là dessus
mais qui permet d'ouvrir les yeux
l'impression qu'on ne se soucient plus
et tandis que je croyais et d'éveiller
les consciences moi j'ai surtout appris
qu'il ya des manières d'utiliser nos les
réseaux sociaux nos téléphones aux
écrans surtout d'une façon très
intelligente et moi je trouve qu'il est
personnellement j'ai utilisé mon
téléphone d'une manière stupide allongé
remonter aux causes pas l'année
aujourd'hui pénélope c'est beaucoup
désinvesti des médias sociaux
et la montre autres échappés les
vedettes des sags ram mais amener chacun
est-ce que c'est utile d'être abonnés
non pas que je me suis désabonné
elle a aussi mis de côté l'entraînement
est l'obsession du corps parfait la
danse reste sa grande passion mais ses
motivations ont changé
[Musique]
maintenant je le fais vraiment pour moi
avec moi quand je danse je sens qu'il
pût fier qui compte pis leur sort de là
avec un gros sourire
[Musique]